What do we do with once our ego is
helped us climb in the dominance
hierarchy is secure a bait?
Why then should we keep looking for a
mate and how to curtail that instinct?
Well,
I think part of the way that you
curtailed headings,
instinct is that you have,
you have this sort of life that you
would have with a mate.
The question is,
you know,
what's the purpose of pair bonding and
one of the fundamental purposes of pair
bonding.
Well there's a couple.
One is that it solves the sexual access
problems so that you don't have to
continue to obsess about who you're
going to be with him and,
and,
and where,
and how.
And so you can get on with other
elements of your life.
But I mean with,
with your mate,
you have to decide,
well,
what does it mean that you're not
together?
You know,
your companionship.
Obviously in friendship and their shared
interests,
you have to decide what they are.
And I would say that you should continue
dating your,
your partner at least once a week or
perhaps twice a week because otherwise
the romance goes out of your life.
But then also you have to decide about
children and eventually about trench
Hildrun because you know you're going to
get old and you're going to get older
and more mature and children are a huge
part of life and they get a bad rap,
which is really unfortunate because,
you know,
maybe I'm,
I'm different in this regard.
Perhaps I am to some degree,
but I never regretted having kids for
even one second because they're so mean.
All of a sudden you have an intimate
relationship with new people that is as
close as any relationship that you've
ever had.
You have the opportunity to make that
relationship as pristine as you possibly
can mean.
It can be a lot of catastrophe involved
in it.
But it's a great opportunity and there's
just nothing wrong with having some
additional people that love you.
You know.
And so what you do is you turn your
attention to the issues of maturity in
your junior year.
Attention away from the issues of being
a juvenile,
and you do that partly by knowing that
it's actually better to do so.
You know,
there's nothing more observed at the 40
year old 20 year old.
It gets ugly and there's something like
there's something like spoiled milk
bone,
it goes off and you have to gracefully
accept the challenges of each stage of
life and things work a lot better when
you do that much,
much better.
And you also have to,
I would say we're calling it perfect
your sex life with your partner and
express what you need and want and teach
each other what's necessary to keep
things exciting and,
and,
and new.
It's not an easy thing to do,
but it's very much worthwhile because
then you can combine sexual excitement
with intimacy and there's no better
combination than that,
so,
and love,
but it can all be nested,
up inside love inside.
You know,
a destiny that's intertwined together.
That's the best you've got,
man.
That's,
that's,
that's what life has to offer.
And so,
um,
that's what you do is you accept the
responsibility of the next stage of
life.
And you don't mourn the past.
I suppose that also means that when
you're young,
you do what young people do and so that
you don't want to do it again.
So.